bang-bang oh did you just try to bang
bang' with me okay
let's really time what while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us trying
to get our lunch money right I'm here
with the beautiful and intelligent
plenty Mara Nova she's got a stupid
sweatshirt on today cuz it's Georgia
everyone knows the Gators lunch money's
now sponsored by block five don't forget
they've got three products you can buy
and sell crypto you can deposit crypto
and get a u.s. dollar loan against your
collateral or you can use my favorite
product as an investor and the user
which is you can deposit crypto nur up
to eight point six percent APY unheard
of interest rates go do your research
check it out at block five dot-com and
go into the description click on that
link so we get credit and everyone
thinks that Polina is super influential
on the Internet so what's going on with
general mattis Mad Dog Madison self is
the former defense secretary and he is
saying that Trump is trying to divide us
you read his statement what did you
think I don't care about the Trump
aspect of it I do in the sense of for
Trump against Trump I am of the belief
that the President of the United States
regardless of who it is has actually
very little impact because of the amount
of checks and balances that we have in
the United States I disagree because I
think the population listens to him and
he acts as a guide for how people view
America etc of course that's leadership
though what I'm saying is that the
president themselves actually doesn't
have nearly as much power as we think
they do they can do certain things
around executive orders and stuff like
that about power in the literal sense
yes look like literal power in terms of
I want to do X and actually put it into
law the checks and balances in the
United States is very disruptive to
somebody who wants to do that what
you're talking about and I agree with
you on is the leadership right and
mattis basically wrote this here's the
thing though you could pretty much have
written this letter about almost any
single leader at the
state local or federal level right he
chose to write it about the president
United States but at the end of the day
what he's saying is stop being divisive
and start trying to unite people and a
perfect example is here in New York City
where we literally have a mayor and a
governor who are fighting with each
other there a little bit yelling at each
other blaming each other for who's
problem that the protests are I think
the biggest issue is that every level of
government we are missing leadership
there is nobody who is willing to take
the reins and say we need to be United
even if Trump does not believe that he
needs to be able to pretend to even
create like a mirage for people to hope
for something again it's not a Trump
thing all right it's not a individual
leader thing right which is what I think
you're saying it is a we need to unite
and not be divisive but again when you
really come from the top nope yes no
because here's why is people already 50%
of people aren't gonna listen to the
president in any year in any year right
because remember when Obama somebody
from the other side of the aisle was
president 50% of the people didn't
listen to him either right and so it's
the politics in general is divisive but
ultimately where people will listen is
in the local communities and that's the
whole point of America's America is the
union of 50 states and the governors and
the mayors and the city council members
and things like that that's where we
need incredible leadership now what I
like to see the president have
leadership of course right what I like
to see the president go on television
and have this message of course but at
the end of the day we know that that's
not gonna happen right and part of it is
look you know I think that the President
of the United States has a very specific
view of the world and you know we you
and I have talked about a bunch of times
it's very helpful in some situations
it's very detrimental in other
situations right and so what we're
seeing here is a complete vacuum of
leadership across both parties across
the entire spectrum because general
mattis comes at it from a very non
political standpoint which simply says
we cannot use the military against our
own sense
sorry I have to disagree he comes from a
very political standpoint said Donald
Trump is the first president my life
champ who does not try to unite the
American people does not even pretend to
try that's pretty political no not at
all because all his whole point is you
cannot use the military against the
citizens period hands down you just
can't do it right there they are they're
similar to the police to protect and
serve this is not to be used against it
and he specifically says in the letter
that the cities that we live in are not
battle spaces they're not and there's no
need to try to quote unquote dominate
the cities that that's asinine and
anybody who served in the military
understands that if they try to do that
these soldiers will put their guns down
you already saw right there was a letter
from I think was the joint chief of
staff commander who came out and he said
listen we are here to protect it serve
these communities we are not here to go
and implement our powers right or our
military might into our cities and so we
have to get control we can't have
violence we can't have it all okay to
play devil's advocate how do you deal
with a situation where the police aren't
properly trained and is to handle a
situation like this so you need to bring
in like people who are trained in the
military it's a false dichotomy it's the
wrong way to look at it in my opinion
because this isn't the police's job the
reason why there is violence and looting
is because the police are taking the
wrong stance if you go the two things
that are happening right now
you don't want to know what the
communities where there's no violence in
looting it's communities where
individuals citizens are armed they've
their own guns they know hey I
ultimately have to protect my own
community and second is in communities
where the police have not tried to
pretend to be the military and stand up
and puff their chest out and said we
were here to establish law and order
instead they have said we hear you we
will walk with you we will protest with
you we will hear you out like we
understand and we agree with you that
this should not happen they've had
empathy and so what ends up happening is
we have a a set of police forces who
believe that force and weapons and all
of these things turns on the people is
how you establish law and order but the
end result completely on you you can't
argue with it is that the United States
cities where there is violence and
looting the police have bucked up and
tried to pop the chest out in the cities
where they've been empathetic they've
listened they've said we are here we are
part of your community we want to serve
you and we will protect you
those are the cities that are not having
feels like themselves are divided well
at the end of the day where's the
violence in the looting is the places
where the police are trying to buck up
in New York City last night literally
when the curfew hit there's videos all
over the internet the police are just
beating people right it's disgusting
it's cowardly there's videos of people
literally on their bicycles going across
the crosswalk and cops walking next to
em with their batons just hitting them
that stuff happens in authoritarian
regimes that stuff doesn't happen in a
democratic world where you have freedom
of speech where you have the right to
assembly right and so we we just have to
get back to the American ideals and
again violence and looting is bad also
racism is bad police brutality is bad
all of these things can be true that's
why I tweeted the other day is we have
to address the issues but also the cops
should be able to prevent violence and
prevent criminal acts in terms of
looting without beating people like it
is possible to do both of those things
and so that's what we're seeing is the
police can't even resist police
brutality during protests against police
brutality do your jobs prevent the crime
prevent the violence but you don't have
to hurt and beat literally physically be
peaceful people
that's all Jack Dorsey is donating 3
million dollars to Colin Kaepernick's
organization know your rights camp what
do you think about this I mean good for
Jack Dorsey the thing is that everything
Jack Dorsey does is a reflection on
Twitter and square right he's donating
what I'm a billion dollars a million no
no but took total he's doing it a
billion dollars and now this another
three million dollars he literally has a
Google Doc word just keep track of all
of his donations look as we continue to
say the number one thing you can do
right Daryl Morey told me this the GM of
the Houston Rockets he said the number
one thing you can do is you can donate
your time the second best thing you can
do is donate your money
right and obviously jack is put his
money where his mouth this is pretty
cool to see that happen and and I'm sure
there was a huge uproar in the NFL
yesterday because of Drew Brees and all
of that so it's interesting just to
watch now you know more celebrities
athletes etcetera are all weighing in on
how they view the view the current macro
environment both on the health side and
on the economic and social unrest side
do you think it's a good thing for CEOs
of these companies to very publicly
share their political opinions I think
that we are in an environment where it
is nearly impossible to not mainly
because if you stay silent you are
complicit yeah right and what I mean by
complicit is it should again it should
not be hard for somebody to come out and
say I disagree and I am vehemently
against racism I disagree and I am
vehemently against police brutality
however I believe that most cops are
good we should find the bad ones and get
rid of them we should not treat people
based on their race differently and
everyone should feel safe in their
country and should have the opportunity
for wealth and happiness look at it like
there's a complex situation but it isn't
just black and white cops are good or
cops are bad right you can have the
nuance and I think it takes courage
people to come out and say that but
we're at a point now where if you're a
leader of an organization you have to do
something right you can't stay silent
because that silence will be mistaken
whether rightly or wrongly as complicit
complete complicit action I guess yes
right word right so say something agree
yeah woo we're agreeing today by the way
update spilled coffee it's all good we
clean the table we clean the carpet we
leave the chair that's right the culprit
picked up after herself after she made a
mess just like she makes me do if I make
a mess she tells me to pick it up I'm
all about equality here in our home in a
future episode I will share the single
best-kept secret to a successful
relationship but not today no not today
what's up with the unemployment
okay so filings for unemployment
insurance claims totaled one point eight
seven million last week so that means
that it's saying the assign that the
worst is over
but that's still pretty high yeah I mean
one point eight million people lost
their jobs last week a fiver on
unemployment claims like that again
going back to the worst week ever on
record before the corona virus hit was
like eight hundred thousand so it's more
than double the worst week ever in
history back in nineteen eighty two and
so you know again we get desensitized to
these numbers because we're just like
one point eight million I saw six
million three weeks ago I saw somebody
say some economists say okay the kovat
recession is over because these numbers
are so good I was like how are they good
they're not good number one rule about
economists don't listen to them don't
worry it's fine
they got a lot of theories but that's
there's not a lot of common sense going
on there with that comment that's
ridiculous
okay speaking of helping the unemployed
stimulus checks bank behalf of Americans
receives stimulus checks can you believe
that I'm surprised it's not hired that's
a total of 267 billion dollars so 260
billion was given to Americans Wall
Street and corporations got more don't
forget you know who got bailed out with
a 3 plus trillion dollars there's 3
trillion dollars that was given out to
67 was in stimulus checks there's
obviously the PPP loan program and then
on top of that there was a beefed up in
unemployment so it's not fair to say
with only 267 million got to the people
but don't forget that literally 267
million of billion dollars went to the
people the airline industry alone one
industry 50 billion dollar bailout so
1/5 of the money that the people got the
airline industry got speaking of
Airlines American Airlines and other
carriers are adding summer flights this
summer
American Airlines everybody knows AAA
American Airlines the best airline
an airline said it plans to fly
fifty-five percent of its domestic
scheduled in July so that means slowly
but surely opening up I don't know where
you know people are gonna go but the big
question is how long does it take to
them for them to get back to like 90
percent I don't know if they'll ever get
back to a hundred percent know why these
there's gonna be a permanent loss of
travel because psychologically people
are going to be scarred from this in my
in my opinion that that could be wrong
I'm curious how do you remember how long
it took for the airline industry to
recover after 9/11 I don't remember
that's a great question now somebody may
know that or we can look it up later
because I feel like that fear it's
probably much more severe than than now
yes and no in the sense of definitely
there was probably psychological like
hey I don't want to get on a plane
because you could crash type stuff but
the other thing was there was things
that you could do to combat it right so
like I remember one of the big programs
they started was hey we're gonna start
putting armed US marshals on it's still
today you can get on a flight today and
in the United States there could be
somebody with a gun who is a government
a US Marshal who basically there that's
what they're trained to do right is they
have a weapon on the flight they have to
carry a thing that shows they're US
Marshal whatever but that was like a big
part of the programs like hey we should
put people with guns on the fight which
is a little scary like the idea of
people shooting guns on a flight yeah
but also at the same time right is with
the virus you can't shoot it right you
can't like put handcuffs on you can't
see it even yeah so it's just like I
think that psychologically that there's
a little bit of a difference there but
again there was definitely a big lag
after 9/11 on the airline industry we
obviously eventually fully recovered
this I think is it's gonna take a while
like I don't think it's gonna be oh you
know in August we're gonna be back to
100% by any means and actually think
that there's a good chance we never get
back to full flight it's pretty
incredible I mean look we got 95 percent
it's closer don't tell that to my 70
year old grandfather who really wants to
come to New York from Bulgaria and he
keeps getting postponed
he wants to come so bad every time we
talk to him on the phone can I come yet
he's like well Gary is getting better
how is New York and I was like don't ask
though what does he know yet about the
riots I think he does we haven't talked
about it yet I haven't called him yeah
if he knows that the protests and riots
are here does that make him want to come
more or less uh probably less less but
he's he's really funny cuz I can't call
him always because he shuts off his
internet I was like I called you the
other day why didn't you pick up like
what are you doing and he was like oh I
shut off my internet look at you two
that we know multiple people in Bulgaria
who they keep shutting off their
internet they think it's like the lights
right like oh I walked out the room I
shut the yeah they like turn on their
internet to use it and they shut it off
and go do something else and you're like
but then I can't reach you and they're
like no no no I got us let you know you
know Monday at 3 o'clock I'll are you
like okay that's fine yeah you're living
in kind of an Internet world not really
what's going on with Carol [ __ ]
Baskin how did I end up on amazon.com I
did not click that I don't know how it
went there that is weird
Wow um okay so it just opened to like
luxury hand soaps come on let's go
what's going on with Carol Baskin are
you ready for this yeah you ready for
this
sheriff confirms that the will of tiger
King star Carol Baskins missing husband
was forged and he's saying this after
numerous experts have said that it looks
like the signature was traced but here's
the thing the they had so the County
Hillsboro County Sheriff had two experts
deem it a hundred percent of forgery but
the problem is that enough time has
passed we can't do anything so the
statute of limitations has expired so
criminal charges cannot be filed against
anybody for a fraudulent will I mean she
is she said she I mean I don't even guys
if I get hurt if I get hurt that was
proof that was evidence how did she pull
this off what do you mean there was no
technology back in the day it's in like
the jungle of Florida
yeah there's nobody paying attention
that's I mean but like let's just say it
right this is my personal opinion she
killed her husband okay do you think
that she did a second so when there is
an active so let's say somebody dies
there's an active investigation into
their death the wife is a suspect
how has nobody at the time making sure
that the will is authentic well again
they probably didn't have the technology
available that they use now to find out
that it was forged and also you have to
remember that like you're talking about
these small towns where people just
don't care right like the I think if I
remember correctly like her brother
worked on the police force too or
something yeah I think that was true and
so it's just like everyone knows
everybody it's the same reason why why
does Jeffrey Epstein get away with what
he gets away with in Palm Beach Florida
is because everyone feels like he's a
celebrity and he's cool with them all
he's donated money to their cause or
whatever you know garbage excuse that
they used to rations come back very
disturbing no he's a scumbag
it's not that hard look your scumbag you
should have went to jail and by the way
the fact they didn't go to jail means
that other people got hurt so every
single person who is part of that
prosecution they're scumbags to you tell
ya the one got the one guy quit his job
because everyone realized that you're a
scumbag we're doing that deal with them
whatever that's fine go back to Carroll
basket yeah like are you surprised that
she's forged it no are you surprised
that she didn't get caught no okay how
does it feel to be Carol Baskins new
husband oh he's so whipped he did you
see the picture of him and he's got like
a collar on she's got a leash I mean
Carol is a charmer hello cats and
kittens can you resist that what would
you do if you met that woman on tinder
swipe the what Swiper away swipe left
swipe left see ya old looking ladies
kill old she's a murderer why don't they
you donation say you know what they
should it's my opinion it's my opinion
they should start every single article
but this would be this would be how how
the media
would cover this if they were really
honest suspected murderer Carol basket
they have no proof she did it
suspected alleged murder but nobody's
alleging I am medias Allah you are the
media is everyone is everyone is
alleging that's what they should start
every article they write about Carol
basket you say suspected murder Carol
Baskin says whatever suspected murderer
Carol Baskin most likely forged her
she's got a new husband she's got a zoo
she's getting skirting the law somehow I
mean how is she doing all this Olivia
cats and kittens soon soon she's gonna
be hitting people with hello my fellow
prisoners all right that's it for lunch
money today well Wall Street's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right polina's got
our Georgia sweatshirt on we'll have a
conversation about that later and we
will see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block 5 so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6% it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks at
block by subscribe to our channel like
the video annoy plain in the comment and
we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends